I'd like to have a word with
the birthday boy.
Can you young men
go away, please?
[whistles]
Thanks.
What did you just wish for when
you blew out the candles?
Nah, I don't think
you're gonna like it.
Whatever you wished for,
whatever it was,
I am going to make that wish
come true.
(Forrest voice-over)
Eric was understandably hesitant
to share a secret wish,
but to make it come true,
I'd have to know what it was.
- What I wished for...
- Yeah?
was for mom and me
to move back to L.A...
Well...
And to move in with
Joe Dale Jr.
Can you really make
that wish come true?
(Forrest voice-over)
Could I?
I did not know,
but this review meant
I would have to try.
That's what you want?
You don't want a go-kart
or anything like that?
Joe says he has five go-karts
at his house.
Oh,
Joe's got five go-karts.
Oh, my God.
(Forrest voice-over)
This was a devastating,
punishing, miserable request.
I came here prepared to
build a go-kart,
which would have been
hard enough.
Instead, I would have to try
and convince
to former love of my life
to move in with a jerk.
[sighs]
Wow, I was just thinking
about Joe in there.
He's fantastic.
What a--what a great guy.
Yeah, he is great.
I-I really like him.
- Yeah. You do, huh?
- Yeah.
So do I.
I didn't know if
it was gonna be hard for you
and I was even gonna tell you
beforehand,
but you were out getting shot
or whatever.
- Did you know this?
- What?
Okay, so whatever, he's sweet,
he's funny, he's handsome.
He's handsome, of course,
but he loves Agatha Christie.
How cool is that?
- Unbelievably cool.
- Yeah.
(Forrest voice-over)
Incredibly enough,
my wise and thoughtful ex-wife
was genuinely smitten
with a man who is capable
of craving a MILF.
But she was still too sensible
to pick up and move
without an invitation.
For that, I would need to
convince my betrayer.
You guys are basically like my
favorite couple I've ever seen.
I like her, man.
Ever since
I started dating her,
whenever I get a little
something on the side,
I feel pretty bad about it.
Did you say that you have
already cheated on Suzanne?
Yeah, but I'm gonna
try not to.
Yeah, yeah.
No, that would be great.
(Forrest voice-over)
Joe did not strike me
as a family man,
but I could not give up.
You should ask her
to move in with you.
Mm, I gotta tell you.
I like to throw
freaky parties, you know?
Like, good-looking women
at the house in the pool.
Yeah, I'm glad
you're saying that,
because that's how
these guys are as well.
They love to throw down
with good-look--
good-looking women in the pool.
It'll just be the same old
Joe Dale Jr.,
just with a loving partner
to come home to
and a little guy
hanging around
who just thinks
the world of you.
- Whoo!
- I can tell you,
I had that, you know.
You could really
literally just
walk down there
and go get it.
Cheers, man.
Who's ready to play?
(Forrest voice-over)
I had tried my best
to make a wish come true,
but I doubted that a shallow man
like Joe Dale Jr.
would make this sort of
commitment to a woman
no matter how great she is.
[dramatic music]
But a week later, I got the call
that Suzanne and Eric
were moving in with him
in Los Angeles.
- I got it. I got it.
- Are you sure?
I got it. I got it. Oh!
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- I got it.
- You got it?
- Yeah, I got it.
(Forrest voice-over)
I had fulfilled my son's wish,
and aside from
the truly awful feelings
associated with
delivering my family
into the hands of
a habitually unfaithful fraud,
I can report that
it was satisfying
to see the wish recipient
so happy.
Dad.
What are you doing here?
Suzanne invited me to stay
in one of Joe Dale Jr.'s
guesthouses.
Sleeping on the floor
in your office
is just doing a number
on my back.
Yeah, Dad, I don't think
that's a good idea.
He's got a pool, son.